Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192. David, you know,
yesterday I played a voicemail where someone
corrected my pronunciation of the city in Texas
where the recent mass shooting took place. And I
explained, you know, the problem is. For me, I see
as a native Spanish speaker, I see it, and for me
it's oubaali. And so I don't know if it's Uvalde
or Uvalde. DE These are all incorrect anglicized
pronunciations. For me, it's Uvalde, but I don't
tend to use those pronunciations because people
get all worked up about it. The voice mail I
received about it. Case in point refers to
my Spanish pronunciations as exaggerated.
That's my whole point. They're not exaggerated.
They're just the pronunciations. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: David, I just want
to say, I love it when you
do your sort of exaggerated Spanish pronunciation.
Speaker 1: This is exactly. He says he loves it,
but he's still calling them exaggerated. I don't
find that offensive. I just find it funny that
just the real pronunciations. Attract so
much attention and are called exaggerated.
They're just the pronunciations is sort of like
if I say Apple, wow, what an exaggerated American
pronunciation of that. No, that's just
how you say Apple in English. It's like
if I'm speaking in Spanish and I refer to the
former president of the United States, I say
Donald Trump. It's not an exaggerated English
pronunciation. It's just the pronunciation.
Speaker 4: Of names and where it's at. I find
it very refreshing and I find it delightful to
listen to. Good. I don't know how to say you
validate. In fact, whenever I hear the word,
my brain immediately goes to Vivaldi.
Speaker 1: The yes, of course, the composer
of the Four Seasons and many other great pieces.
Speaker 4: Italian Baroque composer who wrote the
Four Seasons. And there are two things maybe on
the bonus show and you have time. Maybe you can
like I know you talk about baseball sometimes,
maybe you can read the starting lineup of your
favorite team or something and pronounce
all the names for us. That would be a lot
of fun. Thanks, David. I love the show. Yeah.
Speaker 1: We'll turn it into a we'll turn it
into a sideshow. J.D. Martinez. That'll be
a special that if we get to our 1.5 million
subscribers, I'll just read read Spanish names.
All right. Anyway, it's not a big deal, but it is
funny on the bonus show today, by the way, we will
talk about following the Uvalde School shooting.
Canada is proposing new gun safety regulations.
Canada is doing more as a result of the school
shooting in the U.S. than the U.S. is doing,
at least for now. We are going to talk about
one of the victims that was shot in the
Brooklyn subway, mass shooting, another
recent mass shooting. She is suing the gun maker
Glock for damages. And we're going to talk about
the impact of such a lawsuit. And we have not
spoken about this on the show or the bonus show
at all. But it is finally over. Other than all of
the appeals that are coming, the Johnny Depp Amber
Heard case is finally over. It has captivated
much of the country, although I don't know that
my audience has been that interested in it
for weeks, if not months. Johnny Depp mostly
won his defamation case against Amber Heard. My
interest in it now are the extrapolations that
are being made about the MeToo movement, about
male victims of domestic violence and so many
different things. So we will finally address it
now that it's over. Mostly on the bonus show.
Sign up for the bonus show at join Packman dot
com. You can use the coupon code big voting 22.
But remember, Alex Jones hates the bonus show.
Speaker 5: Oh, the bonus.
Speaker 6: Show where you want to make money
and everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad. Right. Thank you. Your
lucky stars every day. You're not David.
Speaker 1: Pakman. Well, many people do.
Okay. Thank you, Alex. You can sign up at
join Packman dot com coupon code. Big voting
22. All of those stories and more today.